[Music]
this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by the curiosity stream
and nebula bundle deal
watch the latest episode of our new
series the battle of britain on nebula
for just 1479 a year
in 1969 a pioneering vision of the
future made its debut to the public
[Music]
in a few years time the site of concords
on international airfields all over the
world will be commonplace if all goes
well
then there'll be 130 passengers on board
flying times will have been cut by half
london to new york from 7 hours 40
minutes to 3 hours 25
minutes the juxtaposition between this
dated footage and the futuristic plane
is strange
it's hard to believe passengers 40 years
ago in a time when color tv was a luxury
were flying across the atlantic at the
speed of sound
the concorde was well ahead of its time
an anomaly in the history of commercial
travel a byproduct of misguided
government funding a joint venture
between britain's bac and france's
aerospecial and its development funded
entirely by the british and french
governments to the tune of 2.8 billion
dollars
the concord's legacy is married by its
commercial failure but this engineering
marvel was a triumph of ingenuity
nothing remotely close to it had flown
before and nothing like it has flown
since turning what had been a
military-only technology into a luxury
flying experience required innovative
thinking this is the insane engineering
of the concord
the engineers of the concord had several
unique challenges
developing a supersonic plane is
difficult enough
with military design requirements but
developing a supersonic plane that would
satisfy the wealthy customers it
intended to serve
is an entirely different ball game
aerial refueling makes fuel efficiency a
secondary concern for the military the
comfort of the plane's passengers is an
afterthought at best and the price tag
attached to these often limited run
speciality planes is beyond the budget
of a commercial airline
those needs are reflected in the
concorde's unique design a sleek
exterior hiding powerful engines
engines developed from the iconic
british warplane the avro vulcan
fuel efficiency and supersonic flight
are two opposing ideas but these engines
the rolls-royce olympus 593 when flying
at mach 2 were the most efficient
engines ever created
these engines when introduced for the
avro vulcan were capable of generating
just 49 kilonewtons of thrust but over
the course of their adaption for use in
the concorde increased in thrust by over
triple to a whopping
kilonewtons
20 of this thrust increased was provided
by newly fitted afterburners a
technology typically reserved for
military planes
afterburners work by injecting fuel
directly into the superheated and high
pressure exhaust of the turbine section
despite this air's journey taking it
through the combustion chamber only half
of the oxygen in the air is consumed
leaving untapped energy in the exhaust
of these engines
to capture this energy fuel can be
injected directly into the exhaust of
the turbines and ignited basically
acting like a rocket stage of the engine
causing further expansion and
acceleration of the exhaust through the
exhaust nozzle however this system is
useless without a controllable nozzle
typical airliner engines have a fixed
nozzle because these aircraft are
expected to be efficient at a relatively
low range of subsonic speeds
but the concorde with its massive range
of speeds needs not one but two
controllable nozzles to adequately
control the engine's power
the primary nozzle connects directly to
the jet pipe's exit and consists of
petal-like structures that can close or
open to vary the diameter and therefore
the area of the jet's exit
when the afterburner or reheat as the
british engineers called it was ignited
it caused a massive increase in pressure
at the engine's exhaust
this increase in pressure could cause
choked flow in the engine where high
pressure zones ahead of lower pressure
zones will prevent air from flowing
through the engine correctly
to prevent that the primary nozzle opens
wider when the afterburner is active to
decrease pressure and ensure the mass
flow rate through the engine is
unchanged however at times we do want to
affect the flow upstream of the nozzle
the olympus 593 was one of the world's
first predated only by the pratt and
whitney j57 engine by just a couple of
months
two spool means the engine contained two
compressor sections driven by two
turbine sections each acting on their
own concentric drive shafts allowing the
two sections to operate at different
rotational speeds
when the primary nozzle was actuated the
varying nozzle pressure caused the low
pressure spool to either spin faster or
slower thus providing control of the
engine to ensure it can perform at its
optimum speed across its wide speed
range
the secondary nozzle function is just as
complex
the eyelet doors look like some kind of
steampunk blast shield and for good
reason the force these secondary nozzles
had to endure influenced their
appearance
withstanding huge forces at both
supersonic and subsonic speeds and they
could even close completely on landing
to function as reverse thrusters by
actuating these nozzles the plane could
carefully manipulate the exhaust
velocity and thus maximize thrust
because together the pair acted as a
controllable converging diverging nozzle
converging diverging nozzles are
typically used in rockets to accelerate
the combustion products to their optimum
speed and pressure the opposite shapes
are needed because air acts completely
differently at subsonic and supersonic
speeds
for example when subsonic air travels
through a converging duct it speeds up
as the cross-sectional area decreases
until some critical area which is
referred to as the thross
this is where mach 1 would be reached
at this point no further acceleration of
air can occur as the flow is choked now
as you would expect if that same
subsonic airflow went through a
diverging duct the air slows down as the
duct area increases
this is bernoulli's principle at play
the bizarre thing is the exact opposite
occurs when air travels at supersonic
speeds a converging duct will result in
a decrease in velocity and a diverging
duct will result in an acceleration so
in order to maximize the acceleration of
our exhaust gases we want to pass our
subsonic air from the engine first
through a converging nozzle the primary
nozzle until it reaches mach 1 at the
throat
then we want it to pass through a
diverging duct the secondary nozzle at
supersonic speeds so it can continue to
accelerate
these paired nozzles allowed the
concorde to carefully optimize the
nozzle profile for different flight
conditions
a marvelous piece of engineering
the same principles were used for the
inlet
no engine can operate with supersonic
flow the shock waves that would form
inside the engine would cause all kinds
of chaos so the olympus 593 needed some
way to decelerate the supersonic air
entering its unique square inlets
these squared inlets were designed to
simplify the complicated task of
creating nice laminar subsonic flow for
the engine's compressors
inside were a series of ramps and doors
that could open and close depending on
the flight regime the intake was
encountering
at takeoff the engines required all the
air they could get to accelerate the
plane enough to get those cumbersome
delta wings to generate enough lift to
take off
to funnel as much air as possible into
the engine the two variable ramps were
retracted into their closed position
a spill door in front of the engine
intake was held open to allow additional
airflow into the engine while two bypass
doors which control the air around the
cooling passage around the engine were
also closed
the afterburners were also active during
takeoff but soon after the concord was
required to enter a noise abatement
stage of flight where the afterburners
were turned off and power was reduced as
the plane climbed
at this point the bypass doors open to
allow for cooling air to travel along
the outside of the engine
as speed increases the primary and
secondary nozzles adapt gradually
beginning to form the ideal converging
diverging nozzle for supersonic crews
parallel to these changes in the nozzles
the inlet ramps actuate to create a
converging inlet that slows down and
compresses the supersonic air entering
the engine
the fuel consumption of supersonic
flight is massive but that is primarily
driven by aerodynamic drag not thermal
efficiency this supersonic air being
rammed and compressed into the engines
helped the engine immensely in achieving
its high thermal efficiency
thermal efficiency in jet engines is
largely determined by the pressure ratio
achieved by the engine that is the ratio
of pressure between the inlet of the
engine and the outlet of the compressor
which in the case of the concorde flying
a cruise is 80 to 1 an incredibly high
pressure ratio the highly efficient ge
and x engines of the boeing 787 only
manage 58 to 1.
the olympus 593's two spools each
contained seven compressor stages each
driven by a single stage turbine
the low pressure and high pressure
compressors together provided a pressure
ratio of 14 to 1
a moderately high pressure ratio that
would provide moderate efficiency at
subsonic speeds
however the pressure ratio multiplied to
80 to 1 at crews as the supersonic air
rammed into the unique square inlet
engines
this elevated pressure ratio resulted in
extreme temperatures inside the engine
that necessitated the use of high
temperature alloys that are typically
reserved for the turbine blades titanium
blades were used for the early
compressor stages and high temperature
nickel alloys were used in the even
hotter later stages
cooling the driveshaft bearings became
another engineering challenge
increasing the mass flow rate of cooling
oil was not enough to keep the bearings
within a safe operating temperature
looking at the differences between the
original olympus engines used in the
avro vulcan and the concorde hints
towards some changes the engineers were
forced to make
a center bearing located immediately
after the high pressure compressor here
no longer exists in the olympus 593 and
the driveshaft preceding it takes a
bottle-like shape increasing a diameter
in the new gap between bearings
this center bearing had to be removed
because the temperatures were too high
in this location directly after the high
pressure compressor
but without the support of the bearing
the driveshaft became too flexible
to accommodate this change the drive
shaft needed to increase in diameter to
increase stiffness
the concorde is full of strange little
design details like this
solutions to unique engineering problems
caused by the immense cruising speed
in order to decrease fuel consumption as
much as possible the front area of the
plane needed to be minimized
delta wings allow wing spans to be
decreased dramatically and reduce the
drag created in supersonic flight
however it creates some issues for
low-speed flight where they struggle to
generate enough lift making takeoffs and
landings difficult
this is where the argival delta wings of
the concorde come into play
this is a form of compound delta wing
where there are two sections to the wing
with the forward section having a higher
sweep angle than the rear section
connected with an og curve going from
concave to convex curves smoothly
this shape allowed the concorde to
generate additional lift at low speeds
through the use of vortex lift
when flying at high angles of attack
separated airflow would roll over the
wings to form two stable cone-shaped
vortices where air speeds were high and
air pressure was low effectively
creating lift
however those high angles of attack
needed for low speeds created some
serious visibility problems for the
pilots whose cockpit would have had a
lovely view of the sky if not for the
iconic droop snooze
the droop snooze is a one of a kind
solution a mechanized nose that could
drop by 12.5 degrees to provide the
pilots a clear view of the runway during
this high angle of attack maneuvers
the mechanism had four positions
controlled by the pilot with this lever
the top position was the fully retracted
position used in supersonic flight
the second position lowered a
specialized heat shield visor used to
protect the cabin windows from the heat
of supersonic flights when placed in
this position the visor hydraulic
actuator would retract causing the visor
to retract into the nose fairing
the next position was the 5 degree down
position used for takeoffs and taxis
extending this hydraulic actuator and
the final setting pushes the nose down
further into the 12.5 degree setting
needed for landings
the plane also had an extendable tail
landing gear which on most takeoffs and
landings was not needed but was present
to protect the plane's engines which
would be the first point of contact for
what would normally be a tail strike for
other airliners
tail strikes aren't all that uncommon
usually happening on landings in
difficult conditions
some planes like the triple 7 also have
extendable protection measures in the
form of tail skates as a strike can at
best force a plane into maintenance
costing the airline company money or at
worse cause serious damage to the
pressure bulkhead and put the lives of
the passengers aboard at risk
in fact a tail strike is responsible for
the crash that claimed the most lives
out of any single aviation crash in
history
in 1985 a japan airlines 747 flight
crashed in the mountains of japan seven
years after a tail strike had occurred
which had not been correctly repaired
with the high angles of attack demanded
by the concord for landings this
protection was vital to keep the plane
safe
the visor was needed during supersonic
flight because the nose of the plane
experienced temperatures of around 130
degrees celsius while cruising at an
altitude of 60 000 feet where ambient
temperatures are usually around minus 56
degrees celsius
the concord went through several design
iterations with this forward-facing
protection the earliest prototypes
simply removed the lower forward-facing
windows completely
but it turned out that pilots like
having a view of where they are going
so this wasn't an option for the full
production model however a version of
the drip snoot with a fully metal heat
shield was originally considered for the
concorde which would have eliminated
forward visibility during cruise which
was considered non-essential but
thankfully these heat-resistant glass
visors were used in the final version
working with such high temperature
variations between takeoff and landing
causes some serious structural issues
especially with the frequency of flights
needed to make a commercial plane
financially viable
the thermal expansion caused by these
temperatures made the plane grow by 20
centimeters on each and every flight
the fatigue this thermal stress could
cause would eventually result in
catastrophic failure if not properly
accounted for
the first issue was finding a material
capable of dealing with this heat
titanium which was used for the sr-71
could have been used but due to its cost
and weight was ruled out early
traditional aluminium would not be
capable of withstanding these conditions
but a special aluminium alloy
hinduminium rr58
developed in britain during world war ii
for the newly invented gas turbine
engines could
the alloy consists of copper magnesium
silicon iron nickel and titanium with
the remaining percent being made up of
aluminium although this material had
been developed decades prior to the
concord it had never been used in this
application
with lower average temperatures than its
traditional use inside gas turbine
engines but much longer life
requirements the parts would also be
manufactured using different techniques
like the cold rolled sheets needed for
the fuselage
this one process alone affected critical
material properties that improved heat
resistance
forged parts tend to have larger crystal
grain structures than rolled components
which helps forge components resist the
internal crystal structure from creeping
when under stress and heat
to adapt this material for the cold
rolled skin of the concorde the
engineers at rolls-royce had to develop
new manufacturing methods to maximize
the grain size of these cold rolled
components
manufacturing knowledge that has no
doubt been used by rolls-royce for
modern day applications
now that a suitable material had been
developed shaping it in a way that
allowed expansion was crucial
most of this expansion was imperceptible
to the crew and passengers of the
concord interior panels could slide past
each other to hide the expansion to the
passengers and crucially prevented
stress forming as a result of uneven
expansion between the hot exterior and
cool interior
wiring around the plane was given slack
to prevent the wiring from snapping as
the plane expanded and many components
around the plane were corrugated meaning
parts were given a curved shape this
allowed these parts to stretch and
flatten the curves like a spring
however one expansion gap was quite
obvious to the crew of the concorde
as the flight approached its crew speed
a gap between the flight engineer's
console and the cockpit bulkhead began
to form a gap large enough to slide your
hand inside of
or as became tradition for retiring
concords the flight engineer's cap would
be placed inside the gap as it closed
leaving it permanently wedged
like the sr-71 this continual expansion
and contraction cycle caused some
serious issues with fuel tank sealants
in order to deal with the expansion
cycles a sealant needs to be flexible
even mundane plastic sealants on
household windows need this quality to
prevent small movements from allowing
drafts getting through
the issue is that high temperatures tend
to harden sealants over time and then as
the expansion cycles continue the
sealants begin to crack and allow fuel
to spill out
while the temperatures the concord
experienced were vastly lower than the
sr-71 it was still a maintenance issue
the concorde used a high-temperature
sealant called viton but even this
sealant hardened and cracked over time
and so approximately every 1 100 flying
hours roughly once a year the concorde
was forced into maintenance which could
take three weeks to complete
maintaining the vitan seals was one of
the many procedures needed
fuel tanks would be emptied and then
vented for 24 hours to allow technicians
to climb inside and manually inspect and
replace sealant
this was a massive job and often
required the technicians to work with
just touch as access to tanks 5a and 7a
on the outermost part of the wing was
impossible
the concorde had 13 separate fuel tanks
in total taking full advantage of the
large amount of interior volume the
delta wings provided
without these fuel tanks capable of
holding 119 000 liters of fuel the
concorde could not have made it across
the atlantic and would have been
completely useless
to put that volume into perspective a
typical boeing 787 the world record
holder for longest commercial flight can
hold just 34 000 liters of fuel
these fuel tanks played a vital role in
control of the plane too as speed
increases the center of pressure of a
wing the point through which all lifting
force acts tends to move backwards
this is usually not a significant issue
for slower commercial airliners but the
concord center of pressure moved back by
as much as 1.8 meters more than enough
to cause significant control issues that
would push the plane into a nosedive if
not accounted for
usually such a shift would be
counteracted by the elevator which could
stabilize the aircraft in pitch from
changes in the center of pressure
but concorde did not have a horizontal
tail and adding elevons and the wing big
enough to counteract this change would
have resulted in high levels of trim
drag at such high speeds
so concord engineers instead used the
huge tanks they had at their disposal to
deal with this issue as the plane
approached mach 2 fuel would begin to be
pumped out of the forward trim tanks and
into the rear trim tanks and collector
tanks in the wing moving up to 20 tons
of fuel rearwards and shifting the
center of gravity backwards to match the
shift in center of pressure
keeping the plane balanced without
adding any additional drag with control
surfaces an elegant solution using the
tools at hand
the concord is an icon in the history of
aviation i can't help but feel an odd
sense of nostalgia for a plane i never
got to fly in
hundreds of thousands of passengers can
see one of the last remaining concordes
while arriving and departing from
heathrow nicknamed alpha bravo this
concord made its last flight a month
after the tragic loss of air france 4590
it was undergoing major interior
upgrades when the decision to retire all
concords was made stranding the plane
there indefinitely
alpha bravo has been in limbo ever since
never getting to undergo the planned
upgrades to prevent another disaster
like air france 4590
from ever happening again
an unintentional monument to britain's
storied history in aviation accidental
monuments like this are scattered all
across britain gigantic no longer
functional radar towers can be found all
over britain these towers were among the
first radar systems ever constructed and
played a vital role in the defense of
britain during the battle of britain a
system that the germans vastly
underestimated thanks to not just the
technology but the logistical and
strategic systems that supported them
this is the story of our latest episode
of our battle of britain series that
delves deep into how britain's radar
systems worked and how those systems
were integrated into an effective
intelligence system you can get access
to the entire battle of britain series
and our logistics of d-day series by
signing up to the curiosity stream a
nebula bundle deal for a little over a
dollar a month with this yearly
subscription to curiosity stream you can
enjoy the mountain of award-winning
documentaries on curiosity stream and
support independent content creators
like me over on nebula
this is the best way to support this
channel nebula gives us a place to
experiment in safety without any worries
of alienating our current audience on
youtube or being demonetised for
covering sensitive topics like war or
tragic disasters
your support there has helped this
channel evolve and grow and we are able
to give you exclusive content like this
as our thanks you can sign up to this
amazing deal by clicking on this button
on screen right now or if you're looking
for something else to watch right now
you could watch our latest video on the
incredible engineering of the parker
solar probe
or you could watch real science's latest
video on the strange new man-made life
forms xenobots